Film Courage: What are some things that someone
should know before becoming a filmmaker?
Matthew Berkowitz, Filmmaker: Be strong, know
what you want to say, take advice, don’t
always take it and just go, make something
happen and just go make something great.
At least try to every step of the way, write
something honest every day and do your best
to put what you want to write on screen.
Film Courage: You say be strong…is that
meant to resist criticism or can you expand
on this?
Matthew: You should always be able to take
criticism as an artist.
I think that’s part of the job but I think
if you have an intent and a voice and you
want to say something about…you are telling
a story about characters and why people do
what they do and you stick to your principles
and the theory and the thesis of your story
and you hold onto that because you have to
hold onto that for two years.
You have to write a film, you’ve got to
raise the money, you’ve got to shoot the
movie, you’ve got to edit the movie, you’ve
got to make sure this one idea is conceptualized
from the beginning to the end throughout the
entire process.
Film Courage: And then there’s distribution
which is its own beast.
Matthew: And that’s a different side of
filmmaking (the distribution), it’s a totally
different side but just from advice to young
filmmakers is know what you want to say and
do your best to hold onto that every day.
Film Courage: What about in terms of being
on set, do you think you almost have to be
a politician or is it better to be more behind
the scenes because there’s also a downside
to being too much of “the nice guy” because
then someone can take advantage of this or
they think “I don’t have to take this
guy seriously, he’s super cool.
Don’t worry…I can just do this.”
Matthew: That’s kind of what I mean by be
strong.
Filmmaking is about managing egos, managing
people, managing your story, managing your
characters, managing a lot of things.
And all of these things are happening at a
rapid pace.
You have to make decisions as a director,
you have to make a hundred decisions in a
matter in a matter of a minute.
So there’s a lot of politics that get involved.
You want to make sure that your actors are
getting what they want because they understand
the role, you want to make sure that your
DP knows what he’s doing, you want to make
sure that your script is still the same.
You can’t lose sight of a lot of things
that are playing in place.
It’s a difficult way to say you can’t
just be a dictator running your own set.
There’s a middle ground between the relationship
that a filmmaker has with the people involved
because at the end of the day it’s a collaboration
of multiple artists especially even when you
come down to sound design and score.
By the time you finish the film you’ve got
80 people-100 people working on it.
You’ve got at least 12 hopefully ideally
incredible artists that are putting their
voice into your film.
So being a director is about kind of curating
all of those voices and maintaining your own
through the entire process.